I shown in easley being the returning
officer of the parliamentary election
for Stafford constituency held on
thursday seventh of may 2015 do hereby
give notice of the number of births
recorded that each candidate is as
follows for free Kate Labour Party
14,400 29 how Karen National Health
Action Party 1701 Laphroaig Jeremy Jonah
Elton the Conservative Party Camden
23,000 606
liver Keith Liberal Democrats 1348 sure
Mike the Green Party 1390 we build head
UK Independence Party Euclid 6293
rejected papers 173 I do that I declare
that said Jeremy john Felton lefroy is
Julie elected member of the staff
firstly I would just like to thank the
sheriff and the act of returning officer
and indeed everybody who has so
patiently and expertly handled this
election over the last 24 hours thank
you very much indeed secondly I would
like to thank my agent James casual my
wonderful team and my family for their
support during this time but most of all
I would like to thank the electors of
Stafford who gave me the other five
years ago connecting me putting their
trust in me for the past five years and
have again done some I feel most humbled
itís Stafford and Hull constituencies
the most amazing place we have been
through some very very difficult times
but I know that together we can succeed
together we have shown that we are able
to do things that time seeing it
possible we have huge challenges
and we will rise to meet those
challenges thank you